-How are you?
-I'm great. I'm great.
How are you?
-Good.
So you just wrapped up
another season.
How has it been doing
this show for the second time?
-Unbelievable. It really feels
like no time has passed.
-That's so wonderful.
-It is.
-And the fact you guys --
I mean, you obviously maintained
a friendship in all the time
it was off.
But I can't imagine how nice it
is to spend that much time
with your friends again.
-I know.
I mean, we were off
for 12 1/2 years.
So then --
-That's crazy.
-It's crazy!
So then to come back
and to be able to come and laugh
every single day together,
it really is just a gift.
-Because you're --
you did that show,
people might have thought,
you know,
that was the first time
they got to know you.
But you did shows before that.
-Yes.
-Your first show was
in 1995
called "Ned and Stacey."
-Yes.
-And how did that go?
-Um, it went okay.
-Okay. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's a show.
That's hard to do.
-It was a show.
-Yeah.
-It was a show for two seasons.
I had just come from New York.
I had never done
a TV show before.
And it was rolling along.
And there was another show on
at the time called "Friends."
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was doing a little
better than us.
[ Laughter ]
And then one day the producers
come to me and they said,
"Okay, the reason why 'Friends'
is so successful
is because of Jennifer Aniston's
hair."
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
These people worked in
television.
-And I was like, "Her hair?"
And they said, "Yes."
So, they brought her hairdresser
and made him cut my hair
into "The Rachel."
And then, he -- you know,
he blew-dry it.
And I was like,
"Oh, it's 'The Rachel.'"
But the thing is,
he didn't teach anybody
how to blow-dry it.
And so, like,
there's these -- you know,
we in the tribe,
we call it Jew hair.
-Yeah.
-Right?
I had very, very curly hair.
And they're sitting there,
and they're like --
sweating trying to
straighten it.
And then they're quitting.
And then another one
is trying to straighten it.
Then that one quit.
Then another one.
Literally -- literally
three people quit
because they couldn't
straighten my hair.
-So, "The Rachel,"
but, like, here's an example
of this is your best effort.
-This is the best -- It worked.
-There's your "Rachel"
over there.
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
It's like hair that's
dressing up like "The Rachel"
to, like, get through security.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you notice
the mushroom-esque little --
[ laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that was because
it literally, as I was acting,
it was growing.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, David Schwimmer
was on the show this year
playing your boyfriend.
-Yes.
-Did you get a chance to tell
him that the reason "Friends"
was successful because
of "The Rachel" haircut?
-I didn't.
-Yeah, you should have.
-I know.
-I think he would have been
really, really happy
to hear that.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you -- the first time you
did the show, because, again,
you couldn't have expected it
was going to come back.
Did you take anything
from the set
after you wrapped
the first time?
-Yes. Yes. The producer
said, you know,
"What would you like?"
And I said that I wanted the
door from Grace Adler's Design.
-I bet they thought
something smaller.
Right?
-They did.
-Yeah, okay.
But I just wanted the door,
and just thought,
"Oh, like, for art."
-Yeah.
-You know, just lean it up
against a wall
and, you know, see if people
try to actually walk into it.
-Like, that could be
kind of fun.
And, so, I brought it home.
And the next day, I got a call
from someone at NBC,
and they said, "You owe us $25."
-$25?
-And I said, "What? What?"
And they're like,
"For the wood."
-Really?
-Because they could have
broken down the door
and used that wood
for another pilot.
So in order for me to keep
the door,
I had to pay $25 -- $250.
-Oh, it was $250? Okay, got you.
-$250.
But I said, "Sue me."
-That's, I think,
the right way to go.
Because, like, famously,
wood court is so long.
It takes so long to get trial
in wood court.
I'm sure you would have
been fine.
-I think so.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it was, you know,
eight years.
We made them $18 billion.
-Yeah.
-And they're saying,
"You have to pay me $250."
I'm like, pbbbbbt!
[ Laughter ]
-I just picture,
there was, like,
some carpenter came in.
He was like,
"Hey, where's the door?
We were counting on that door!"
-"Go talk to Messing."
-Yeah. "I got to get my money
from Messing."